- Hello, I'm Rian Johnson.
- Hi, everybody.
I'm Chandrabose.
- My name's Paul Mescal.
- And this is love letters...
- Love letters.
- Love Letters from Letterboxd.
- A little love. A little love
right there. Ooh.
Little mood change.
- I'm going to open this up
and find out what
this letter says.
“Best 103 minutes of my life.” Wow.
- “I think it's safe to say
that all was quiet
in my living room
after watching this masterpiece.”
You are too kind.
- “I love the songs.
Crying face.”
But I'm having a
smiling face here.
- “We as a culture must
let Paul Mescal dance.”
He's probably referencing the “Under Pressure” sequence
with some questionable
dad dancing.
And I agree.
I feel like we as a culture
must let me dance
even though I'm not
that good at it.
- “Heck, yeah.
I saw “Top Gun: Maverick”
in theaters
for a third time
and I'd do it again.
This time was laser
focused on the editing of
Eddie Hamilton and
Chris Lebenzon.
Those two guys kept it tight.”
Thank you very much.
That's awesome.
- “Naatu naatu
naatu naatu, naatu naatu, naatu naatu
Pauses to wrestle a tiger and shoot a gun.
Naatu naatu, naatu naatu, naatu.
Thank you very much.
- “That f wolf was
terrifyingly hot.”
This person saying
the wolf is hot
is not the only
person saying that.
- “The real star was
Angela Bassett's hair.”
I'm sure Camille will love that.
- “The real star was
Angela Bassett’s hair.”
I like that one.
It was a such a transition
from the first one
where she had the long locks.
And I'm just so happy that people loved it and enjoyed it.
- “Here's the beautiful thing
about all of this.
Todd Field has no interest
in easy answers.
“TÁR” is a movie
that trusts the intelligence
of its viewers, that demands
attention to detail and wants
to start a discussion rather than tell you what to think
or how to feel.”
Thank you Marianna.
Well, Letterboxd is a big part of our cinematic life.
Something that I read
quite a bit
and that I feel like I learn from.
- “A twisty turny tale
with a sharply written script
and featuring Daniel Craig
in what seems to be
his favorite role.
“Glass Onion” was a
ton of fun.”
Oh, Deirdre!
He is having a ton of fun
when he plays Benoit Blanc,
and that means it's
a good environment on set.
That means everyone's
having a good time and
that's what we want.
- “I know Michelle Yeoh
was going to give
an amazing performance, which she absolutely did,
but it was Ke Huy Quan who stole the show.
The innocence in his character,
and at the same time,
the badass version of his character is portrayed
brilliantly by him.
He was terrific.”
All the kindness that you all have shown me
has really warmed my heart.
You have made this a really
emotional journey for me,
so I thank you
from the bottom of my heart.